mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
wer ist banksy und wo taucht sein
nächstes werk auf der anonyme britische
street art künstler elektrisiert die
massen
100 originalwerk höheres privatem besitz
werden nun in basel ausgestellt
ohne zustimmung von banksy reine
geldmacherei mit seinem prominenten
namen oder wird hier ein künstler mit
seinen eigenen waffen geschlagen
außerdem sophie passmann 27 jährige
feministin und comedian ihr neues
selbstkritisches buch wir kommen auf dem
postplatz wir widmen uns heute dem
phänomen banksy
[Musik]
die werke des britischen street art
künstler sind weltberühmt doch seine
identität ist bis heute ungeklärt
banks ist graffitis tauchen seit 20
jahren an den hauswänden dieser welt auf
es die klare botschaften gegen krieg
kapitalismus und gegen soziale
ungerechtigkeit
doch inzwischen ist banksy selbst eine
kapitalistische größe und viele
profitieren von seinem namen so etwa
eine italienische kuratoren gruppe die
mit einer nicht autorisierten banksy
ausstellung international unterwegs ist
[Musik]
passt genau zu der wieder eröffneten
museum macht diese bank die ausstellung
in der basler messe station
[Musik]
hier in der messe basel werden 100
originalwerke sowie eine skulptur und
objekte des britischen künstlers banksy
gezeigt es sind werke die bank sie
verschenkt oder für wenig geld verkauft
hat hinter der ausstellung steht eine
galerie aus london und ein italienisches
kuratorenteam stefan antonelli alles was
hier gezeigt wird stammt aus privatem
besitz wie haben sie es geschafft diese
ausstellung auf die beine zu stellen
bankster motto praktikum bei banksy ist
es speziell es gibt von ihm keine
öffentlichen sammlungen
als wir uns vorstellen planten die bank
sie ist 20 jahre lange arbeit
untersuchen sollten mussten wir viel
reisen wo die werke bei privaten
sammlern zusammensuchen wird galileo
press
wir mussten die echtheit der werke
abklären alles in allem eine arbeit von
acht jahren
wenn wir uns etwas über die privaten
leihgeber sagen
normalerweise ist es so
es sind reiche die ihre werke den museen
für ausstellungen zur verfügung stellen
hier gibt es auch werke die einfachen
arbeitern gehören das könnte den
künstler gefallen
er vertrete er die idee dass kunst allen
sozialen klassen gehören soll
virtuelle klassik was ist der zweck
dieser ausstellung vision basel ag
banksy weist uns auf dinge hin über die
er selbst sagt sie interessiert
niemanden hier herne solothurner
gerechtigkeit frieden
neid man freiheit er bringt diese themen
der massen ehre
in dieser ausstellung werden wohl viele
menschen kommen die noch nie in einem
museum behalten danke wir sprechen
später weiter denkt sie selbst hat sich
ausdrücklich gegen solche ausstellungen
geäußert er ist nicht damit
einverstanden dass mit seinem namen und
ohne sein einverständnis geld gemacht
wird immer wieder versucht sich banksy
gegen die kommerzialisierung seiner
kunst zur wehr zu setzen wir versuchen
der bank sie phänomen etwas auf die spur
zu kommen
die ratte ist sein markenzeichen ein
tier das bank sie in vielem endet sie
ist verspielt versteckt sich gern
ist im schutz der dunkelheit unterwegs
und offenbar ein entspannter kumpel
[Musik]
nach der ratte hat banksy seine firma
blatt sie heißt pest control
schädlingsbekämpfung und nimmt die
authentifizierung seiner werke vor die
basler ausstellung zeige originale sagen
die kuratoren alle werke hätten ein
echtheitszertifikat von fest control
doch was heißt schon original bei bank
sie das fragen wir den kunsthistoriker
ulrich blanchet in interviews hat er
gesagt die werke auf der straße sind die
originale und das was man als druck
kauft das ist im endeffekt im juni also
das ist nicht der eiffelturm selber
sondern es ist eine postkarte vom
eiffelturm das richtige bilde kunstwerk
ist natürlich dass draußen auf der
straße
die bank sie ausstellungen die rund um
die welt gezeigt werden sind alle ohne
einbezug des künstlers entstanden
unautorisiert also pest control ist da
deutlich
diese ausstellungen sind nicht echt und
könnten misst sein
kommen sie dann bitte nicht zu uns um
geld zurückzufordern wisst wie dort soll
auch banksy ist kunst im innenraum
natürlich er gratis für alle sein banksy
hat auf seiner webseite für die art
unautorisierte ausstellung extra einen
so genannten produkt rückruf gestartet
und sie als fake schoss bezeichnet die
ohne sein einverständnis durchgeführt
werden echte banks die ausstellungen
haben in den letzten 20 jahren
normalerweise gar keinen eintritt
gekostet
der eintritt in basel kostet 25 franken
doch gemäss den kuratoren sei die
ausstellung lediglich kostendeckend und
ein non-profit-unternehmen aber mit
banksy es motiven lässt sich viel geld
verdienen
gegen das merchandising ist er
erfolgreich rechtlich vorgegangen
pest control schreibt banks sie macht
kunst und kunst ist etwas das es vorher
nicht gab
merchandising ist wenn man ein kunstwerk
nimmt und es auf einen toilettenpapier
halter klebt denkt sie macht kein
merchandising
sein blumen werfer ein ikonisches bild
das er in palästina malte das motiv
wurde zu einem markenzeichen bank saß
und von einer postkarten firma gekapert
gegen die ihr vergeblich klagte denn
eine bedingung für markenschutz wäre die
anonymität aufzugeben und das will bank
sie auf keinen fall
denn nach ratten art will er weiterhin
klandestin zuschlagen können bank sie in
der londoner u-bahn und seine ratte als
corona maskottchen mit der message wenn
du keine maske text kapierst du es nicht
banksy schwenk sie wehrt sich gegen ihre
ausstellung haben sie schon post von
seinen anwälten bekommen wir haben keine
post erhalten von seinem heimweh aber
der künstler ist nicht einverstanden
damit
nun wird es interessant sie ist er eben
dieser künstler der uns gelehrt hat das
ist wichtig sei in der kunst regeln zu
übertrieben
als kuratoren folgende genau dieser
lektion
wir ignorieren das ungeschriebene gesetz
dass der künstler einverstanden sein
muss mit einer ausstellung von dem lot
ist
ich frage mich noch etwas anderes wie so
zeigen sie kunst von der straße in einer
ausstellung die streetart ist zuerst
einmal nur eine ausdrucksform von banksy
kommt dazu dass seine arbeiten im
öffentlichen raum an wenn oben schon zu
sehen wären aber in der realität sind
fast alle mittlerweile zerstört nicht
mehr sichtbar
was denken sie es ist kunst die für mich
ist banks ist kunst vielmehr ausdruck
davon dass man manchmal die regeln
brechen muss und die arbeit an der
freiheit voranzubringen
[Musik]
ja wir verweilen hierbei banks werken
widmen uns aber zuerst noch einer frau
der stunde
die deutsche junge autorin sophie
passmann legt nach ihrem erfolg alte
weiße männer bereits ihr nächstes buch
vor komplett gänsehaut ist die witzige
analyse des deutschen mittelstandes wo
sich auch sophie passmann selbst dazu
zählt wir stellen sie ihnen vor sophie
passmann ist ein phänomen
mit ihrem erst 27 jahren hat sich schon
eine steile karriere hingelegt sie ist
moderatorin komikerin und autorin und
eine ikone im netz mit millionen von
klicks
aufgewachsen ist sie in der deutschen
mittelschicht und genau darauf zielt ihr
neues buch komplett gänsehaut da sitzt
sie den alltag ihrer mail an ihre
freunde
scharfsinnig schonungslos und geistreich
es geht darum faktor für die welt zu
sein
in dieser pseudo asiatischen futterneid
es geht immer um das was fehlt
mir ging es auch darum so ein bisschen
diese haltung die oft sehr belohnt wird
nämlich erst mal alles doof zu finden
gegen alles zu sein und die die neue
platte die alle gerne hören absichtlich
scheiße zu finden dass so ein bisschen
am ende zu demaskieren als das was es
ist nämlich nicht so interessant wie die
leute die passen immer tun
sophie passmann ist frech laut und
witzig das hat sie sich schon früh von
anke engelke abgeguckt
die erste lustige frau die ich im
fernsehen gesehen habe da ist mir das
als kind das hirn explodiert weil ich
dachte auch so mädchen dürfen auch mega
lustig sein das musste ich nicht im
poetry slam debütiert sie mit 15 gewinnt
preise wird radio moderatorin und
studiert politikwissenschaft und
philosophie
sie wird geld schreiberin bei der late
night show neo magazin royal von jan
böhmermann und zeigt sich immer wieder
als moderne feministin
zumindest muss geht nicht ohne dass
frauen zu wort kommen auch wenn ihr
männer ist irgendwie gut meint aber ich
aber ich bin doch auch für ihn ist
darüber müssen wir reden darüber reden
wir mit dem männlichen blick auf
feministinnen setzt sie sich in ihrem
bestseller alte weiße männer von 2009 10
auseinander
darin fühlt sie in gesprächen mächtigen
männern auf den zahn und benennt bei
roger schawinski die auf der bremse
stehen an meint damit den arrivierten
der akademie kann man der konservativ in
der welt rum steht und sagt warum
verändert sich die welt wir hatten die
letzten 30 jahre doch so gut
ein millionenpublikum erreicht sophie
passmann auf prosieben mit ihrer
moderation von männerwelten einer
fiktiven ausstellung über sexuelle
belästigung gegenüber frau
das ist zeitgenössische kunst würde ich
sagen weil diese ja ein so genanntes big
picture transfer kunst und das kriegst
du einfach zu verfügen geschäft von dem
künstler selbst ungefragt die paz manche
passion aber ist das netz sie unterhält
ihre 222.000 follower auf instagram mit
fast täglichen post da lässt sie neben
self es auch immer wieder politische
haltungen aufblitzen und überzeugt mit
humor ich wenn jonathan sagt hübsches
elvis machen feminismus kaputt bei
verschwörungstheoretikern aber kennt
selbst die satiriker in keinen spaß
was mich immer aggressiv macht andeuten
diese verschwörungstheorie videos
weiterleiten da steckt ja drin
ich habe als einzige die wahrheit
erkannt ihr engagement hat eine
hässliche kehrseite als frau die witze
in der öffentlichkeit macht bekommt sie
sexistischen hass zu spüren
sie habe shitstorm es für jahrzehnte
dann kommt natürlich wirklich der
schlanke frauen hast dann kommen die
vergewaltigungs fantasien dann kommen
die mordfantasien dann kommen die ich
weiß wo du wohnst fantasien dann kommen
auch die warum bist du so hasserfüllt
dir fehlt mal ein richtiger mann
aber ich denke ja also das kleinste
problem ist wirklich zu wenig männer in
meinem leben
sophie passmann eine frau die sich mutig
exponiert und etwas zu sagen hat und
millionenfach gehört wird
ihr anspruch ein vorbild zu sein
ich versuche vor allem jungen frauen zu
zeigen man kann genauso hart und genauso
böse und genauso lustig sein wie ein
mann
und es ist immer noch kein grund dass
man auch irgendwie verbrannt wird als
hexe und ich habe die hoffnung dass das
was ich genau das was mich ermächtigt
dinge zu tun
andersrum andere ermächtigt in ihrem
neuen buch teilt sie gegen alle aus am
bösesten aber gegen sich selbst und
ihresgleichen
das macht komplett gänsehaut doppelt
lustig und lesenswert
[Musik]
das zu einem ganz anderen phänomen
unserer zeit auch in der schweiz nimmt
die zahl der jugendlichen zu die sich in
ihrem körper nicht richtig fühlen aber
eine geschlechts änderung in
jugendlichem alter ist natürlich noch
von viel größerer präsenz wir fragen wie
geht ein mensch in diesem alter mit
diesem wunsch nach geschlechts änderung
um
[Musik]
wir kommen auf die welt mit einem
geschlecht einen männlichen oder einem
weiblichen das geschlecht ist eines der
merkmale das und später als personen
definiert neben der biologischen gibt es
eine soziale entwicklung die bestimmt ob
wir uns als männlich oder weiblich
definieren
immer wieder können jugendliche das
geschlecht mit dem sie geboren wurden
nicht akzeptieren wie leoni er kam als
mädchen auf die welt hat sich aber immer
als junge verstanden
[Musik]
das hat ein kreativ vier vorgefahren
hatte war nicht ganz klicks ich bin hat
es mich gefangen habe und ich auch
weiter wenn ich einmal im abteil
gegangen und hatte bis kurz vor dem
abteilung und trotzdem immer mit seiner
frau abteilung dass es auch nicht merkt
ich halte generell und auch wenn ich
gerade bin im tretauto das so nicht
immer man das schwarze kleid was halt
irgendwie möglich wenn man so pubertät
ruhig und einfach mal gut gegangen wo
geführt haben mit der pubertät begann
leonel seinen körper abzulehnen
wir haben immer gesehen dass sich mini
liebliche kollege kräuter 19 bis über
handel so aber die kosten für mich dass
ich gold will
und das hat dann ja wenn ich jetzt
komisch oder was ich mit mir dass ich
das nicht will dass mich das zerstört
als ich bei weniger überfordert mit der
situation
es ist falsch es ist nicht schnell man
das team braucht man noch einmal den
bartwuchs und ich habe schon jetzt prüft
und mini und dass ich auch für mich
falsch sie das hat mit seiner sie ist so
oder so sie wie jetzt mini männlicher
kollege
leonel entwickelte eine essstörung und
depression mit 14 hörte er das erste mal
von trans identität und für ihn war klar
das war eher ein junger im körper eines
mädchens er wollte seinen körper
verändern und begann mit 16 mit einer
hormontherapie
[Musik]
auf tester das ist meine stimme vier
monate auf testo dass meine stimme sechs
monate oft ist das meist ein jahr auf
testo
die hormone stoppen leonel weibliche
pubertät und das testosteron erzeugte
männliche körpermerkmale dagmar pauli
hat in den letzten zehn jahren 150 trans
jugendliche auf ihrem weg begleitet
solche eingriffe in die entwicklung
eines teenagers sind sehr heikel
wir helfen den familien und ich sage
bewusst familien das ist nicht einfach
nur das kind oder der jugendliche eine
gute entscheidung zu treffen
und wenn menschen nicht urteilsfähig
sind dann müssen wir ihnen helfen das
dann eben langsam zu werden indem wir
alle informationen anbieten und sagen
schau dir diese verläuft dann schau dir
das an es gibt diese von nachteile und
dann wirklich gemeinsam gut überlegen ob
das der richtige weg ist zum beispiel
eine medizinische maßnahme zu machen
pubertäts blogger kann man zwar absetzen
aber im schlimmsten fall führen sie zur
unfruchtbarkeit und sie ebnen den weg zu
operativen eingriffen meisten
operationen im erwachsenenalter erfolgen
es gibt aber auch fälle wo zum beispiel
einem ass tec to me bei trans männern
die sich schon vermenschlicht haben mit
bart und stimmbruch wo dann das sehr
unpassend ist noch mit dieser brust dann
kann die auch schon vor dem achtzehnten
geburtstag durchgeführt werden aber nur
bei urteilsfähigkeit wenn man dann
natürlich alle konsequenzen und so
weiter gut besprochen hat
auch leon hingeht nicht den halben weg
zwei jahre nach seiner ersten
testosteron spritze lässt er seine
brüste entfernen
er weiß jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr
es ist nett es fehle da sich der wagen
regel will ich möchte die operation
eigentlich seitdem sind ohne dass ich
mich wohlfühle sondern in reinach mit
mir selber ein eigenes labor eines
lagers nicht das will er schon vor der
gesellschaft wenn du es nicht machst
sage immer dass frau xia also spätestens
ein jahr später merken die meisterlich
dass du eigentlich bist und für mich ist
das einfach und nicht kurz fühlen könnte
in den letzten jahren nahm die zahl der
jugendlichen zu die den wunsch nach
geschlechts angleichung äußern
trans identität ist auch medial ein
thema geworden ist dieser
selbstbestimmung über das eigene
geschlecht ein phänomen des zeitgeistes
oder trauen sich trans jugendliche
endlich das zu sagen was sie fühle als
erstes mal in der kirche zunahme als ein
phänomen des früheren outings das ist
auch mehr in den sozialen medien
diskutiert wird das stimmt aber bis
jemand hier in dieser sprechstunde
landet und dann wirklich so ein
leidensdruck hat und mir so stark auch
beschreibt wie die zum beispiel die
ablehnung des eigenen körpers und wie
sich das über dieses ganze
lebensgeschichte schon entwickelt hat
und wie es als kind schon war also das
merke ich doch ob jemand vielleicht
jetzt einfach mal irgendwas im internet
gelesen hat doch es gibt die ersten
fälle von jugendlichen die es später
bereuen
in england hat eine patientin eine
klinik verklagt weil sie sie als sie
noch minderjährig war nicht von der
therapie abgehalten hätte
heute mit 23 liga del wieder als frau
leben
sind die ärzte damit verantwortlich wenn
man davon spricht es könnte jemand
darunter leiden dass man eine falsche
entscheidung getroffen hat und die
bereut dann nehme ich das sehr ernst ich
möchte das auch nicht und ich möchte das
verhindern durch sorgfältige abklärung
wir müssen aber auch von den 97 prozent
anderen sprechen die sehr sehr stark
leiden wenn sie behandlungen nicht
bekommen und wenn sie in einer pubertät
die sich total falsch anfühlt und nicht
nur dann sondern das ganze leben lang
von dem gibt's ja unbestritten ganz
viele und das ist die mehrheit das
streite glaubt niemand
dieses leiden müssen wir doch dagegen
halten und auch berücksichtigen und dann
ist debatte die werte schon viel
differenzierter was ich waren mit die 20
schüler stimmt ja denn ich liebe ja dann
weiß man was man machen als es gibt
operation aber jetzt reversibel sind
oder raum mit der monheimer jetzt wenn
man die nummern im team wird immer
beliebter so tief ich habe so lange
eigentlich den blättern im falschen
körper und jetzt das recht glücklich bin
so wie sie sich für mich schon
bestätigen nur dass es richtig ist
der weg zum anderen geschlecht ist lange
und schmerzhaft vor allem für
jugendliche die entscheidungen treffen
für den rest ihres lebens denn ob sie
beim anderen geschlecht ankommen bleibt
ungewiss
[Musik]
er sagt ja gesagt sagte er
das ist es gab wie sie hier vermisst
wir haben zum schluss geht es bei uns um
musik und wir stellen ihnen eine stimme
vor die uns verzaubert hat lehr maria
fries heißt sie kommt dass luzern und
nun endlich stellt sie ihr solo album
vor unser tipp der woche
[Musik]
wo
face com
[Musik]
wurde
das schon
[Musik]
st
lea maria fries in ihrem element
die gries halo hätte schon vor einem
jahr veröffentlicht werden sollen
doch corona kam dazwischen menten aber
entschieden dass augen mit cell
veröffentlicht werden
bis jetzt muss es muss jetzt die
luzernerin vereint verträumte
kompositionen und fließende klänge
das album ist eine sammlung sämtlicher
momentaufnahmen ihres lebens zart und
impressionistisch
inspiration natur das ist wirklich alles
rennt badesee oder sehr wasserreich
immer wichtig dass ich extrem aber fort
und zu direkt und da irgendwie so zensur
oder aufmacht
[Musik]
ich würde mir die sache nicht spüren
mutig los weil ich dachte je nachdem
oder liefen ganz klar und deutlich und
irgendwie vielleicht mit acryl oder
metall melodie user oder ein text und
denn es ist ganz klar dass
zusammengehört
pieces
[Musik]
die töne
lea maria fries performt in
verschiedenen projekten hier ist ihr
gefäß das quartett den festen wohnsitz
hat sie heute in paris das debüt album
soll im april aber im luzerner club
neubarth getauft werden
[Musik]
sich ein sachlicher der harz und findet
von lothar und ich habe doch city lang
doch klappt und hunger immer wieder
durch die zurück ich habe doch soll sich
so homebase und für mich ist klar dass
ich unbedingt auch lozano platte schafe
und präsentieren und hoffen
bald ist es hoffentlich soweit diese
sängerin und ihre musik gehören einfach
vom publikum
[Musik]
die jubi
exit through the gift shop so heißt ein
film von banksy im bewusstsein dass
kunst eben doch von kaufen kommt so wie
auch hier das war unser ausflug zu einer
etwas zwiespältigen kunst erfahrung die
ausstellung hier über banksy ist noch
bis ende mai zu sehen
nächste woche da schauen wir nach
fukushima und treffen einen schweizer
fotografen der seit zehn jahren immer
wieder am ort der katastrophe ist da ich
jetzt davor die serie auf sf1 mit dem
namen vor sie würden kommen sie gut
durch die woche
[Musik]
platz
sixt
[Musik]
den nötigen strom
mendig
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos